hi I'm Zack woods and I'm gonna give you
some tips about how to survive in the
woods so that's that's cute
first tip is when you go camping
dressed like a southwestern pervert I
look like a voyeur from Albuquerque and
I find that that keeps people at a
distance
you know a lot of times when you're in
wilderness people say don't drink the
water
that's something that it's actually
safer to drink stagnant Creek water and
most rubaba waters worse you're gonna
get as Giardia kayak is actually an old
Iroquois were meaning small emasculating
boat this is called a front a front side
a thali and what you do is you just get
the nose of the canoe
okay well the currents are sabotaging me
but you get the idea
all right I'll meet you guys down river
it's just I told you I'd meet you
downriver
you're being clean teeth cut it out okay
we're in the creek we're fishing
fly-fishing Hunter s Thompson had some
sort of sassy Kate Middleton style booze
fish are attracted to deeply disturbing
imagery so a red eyed mouse wet mouth
sparks that spice ected at the middle is
right as that's their sweet spot they'll
really go for that give a man a fish he
eats for a day teach a man to fish and
he feels condescended to and still
hungry because it's you know that's a
long learning curve
[Music]
rather than catching a fish with this
I'll just find a fish and I'll talk him
into suicide I mean it takes more
emotional work but it's actually not
that hard to make a fish feel
existential despair he's like what are
you even doing man what mark are you
going to leave on this world and before
you know it the fish is banging his own
head against a rock and then dinner but
you can taste their depression when you
eat it where there's fish there's bears
so when you're in the woods always be on
the lookout for bears or twinks or
leather daddy's just depending on what
your type is and that's truly everything
you need to know about fishing there's
literally nothing else
[Music]
hello I didn't see you there
if you get lost in the woods don't
immediately cut your arm off it should
never be a first resort
I know tens of people who have cut off
their arms it's really sad because a lot
of them were pianists or administrative
assistants then it ruined their careers
they can't type work like sedimentary
rock igneous rock would never humiliate
itself like that just coming apart
gross damn it geez this is an it's an
American bald eagle and he's absolutely
filthy you know it's over five pounds of
fruit by the foot every day what a lot
of people don't know is that an adult
bald eagle eats very similar to a
neglected adolescent boy I'll hunt with
Ian we'll go on hunting expeditions
together mostly we're hunting for
bargains so I'll take in to Marshalls
Ian's a jealous bird so I have to be
careful how I behave around other birds
see the mere mention of other birds and
he goes haywire it's not a safe
relationship for me but I don't know how
to get out of it here we are at the end
of our adventure and to recap remember
to survive in the wilderness step one is
admitting you have a problem
step two is remembering that you're
powerless over your addiction
step three is wait what so that's it I'm
gonna go into this this murder hutch and
take a nap what I do and there's my
business
[Music]
goddamnit Keith